Hello, welcome to Michael's Better Business English.
This month, we're looking at a topic that many Japanese people find difficult to handle: Compliments.
Now, especially in the workplace,...
...most Japanese people don't pay or receive compliments so often.
However in some cultures such as American culture,...
...people often use compliments as a positive conversation starter,...
...or to build a friendship with their co-workers.
So, what should you do if you want to pay a compliment to somebody in your office?
First, we often say something personal,...
...a personal feeling about the object of the compliment.
For example, "I really like that shirt on you."
"It really suits you."
Also, we might say how it appears.
For example, "I really like that shirt."
"It looks very smart."
When receiving compliments, here there are two things we could do.
When receiving, the first thing is we could give some detail.
For example, "Thanks! I'm glad you like it."
"I bought it last week in New York."
This extra detail helps develop the conversation.
Or if you wanted to be modest, you could downplay the compliment.
We normally do this by focusing on how we feel about the object of the compliment,...
...rather than the object itself.
For example, "Thanks! I really like that design."
"That's why I bought it."
This is a subtle way to change the topic a little bit from the compliment itself.
So, now you know how to pay and receive compliments.
Thank you and good luck!